OK.
Donald Trump's press secretary, Kaley McEnany,
visibly and oddly audibly failed to explain
why Donald Trump is accusing TV host Joe Scarborough
of murder on Twitter during a press briefing
yesterday.
This was, I believe, her shortest press briefing
in a long time.
I think it was 16 minutes only.
She barely takes questions and often just
aborts when it gets a little bit dicey.
And you have to see this to believe it.
So to catch you up.
Yesterday, I told you that Donald Trump spent
the weekend as the United States coronavirus
death toll approached and has now surpassed
100000.
Trump spent the weekend not just golfing,
but also retweeting that Hillary Clinton is
a skank and accusing MSNBC host Joe Scarborough
of murder.
I showed you these tweets yesterday.
We'll go over them one more time.
Trump tweeting, quote, A lot of interest in
this story about psycho Joe Scarborough.
So a young marathon runner just happened to
faint in his office, hit her head on his desk
and die.
I would think there is a lot more to this
story than that.
An affair.
What about the so-called Investigator Reid
story referring to a three year old right
wing nut story?
Trump also tweeting a blow to her head body
found under his desk left Congress suddenly.
Big topic of discussion in Florida.
He's a nut job with bad ratings.
Keep digging, use forensic geniuses.
And as I told you yesterday, what this all
relates to is a Scarbro staffer that tragically
died in 2001.
The woman was 28 year old Laurie Castlewood
US.
That clip pursuits may be better, better pronounced.
And of course, Caylee McEnany was asked about
this.
And the nearly two minute answer that she
gives is bizarre.
It's a combination of what about ism, condescension,
incompetence and lies.
Let's look at it together.
And I apologize for subjecting you to a little
more than 90 seconds of this, but I think
it is important to understand the full answer
that she gave or not answer that she gave.
Why is the president making unfounded allegations?
He's not accusing somebody of possible murder.
The family is pleading with the president
to please stop unfounded conspiracy theories.
Why do you do it?
Well, you know, I would note that the president
said this morning that this is not an original
Trump thought on and it is not, in fact, 2003
on Don Imus, his show, it was Don Imus and
Joe Scarborough that joked about killing an
intern, joked and laughed about.
So as I was, I'm sure, pretty hurtful to Lori's
family and Joe Scarborough himself brought
this up with Don Eyedness and Joe Scarborough,
who's the president of the United States,
and he's accusing somebody of possibly murder.
This is different.
He's he's he's not a private citizen.
He's the president.
And Joe Scarborough, if we want to start talking
about false accusations, we have quite a few
we can go through about MIGA asserting about
the president's allegation and our time to
you and saying this morning, as recently,
I believe, was this morning or yesterday,
Mika accused the president of being responsible
for 100000 deaths in this country.
That's incredibly irresponsible.
They've dragged his family through the mud.
They've made false accusations that I won't
go through that.
I would not say from this podium against the
president of the United States and they should
be held to account for their falsehoods.
Joe Scarborough should be held to account
for saying people will die by taking hydroxyl
fluorocarbon.
Never mind the millions of Americans and people
across the world who take it for reformatory,
our arthritis and other reasons.
There are a litany of false headlines like
Nikah fronting a false conspiracy theory that
I was a boy.
He's acts possible for murder.
I would point you back to Joe Scarborough
laughed and joked about this item on Don Imus,
the show.
It's Joe Scarborough that has to answer these
questions.
Why is the president doing this?
Was the question, why is the president accusing
someone of murder?
And the family of the victim is saying, please
stop.
Kelly McCann.
And his answer is Trump didn't come up with
the idea that Scarborough murdered someone.
And Joe Scarborough and Don Imus joked about
murdering an intern once.
Now, joking about murdering an intern might
be in bad taste, but it had nothing to do
with this actual death.
To say Trump is justified in tweeting that
maybe Joe Scarborough killed Laurie loudest
has nothing to do with Joe Scarborough and
Don Imus joking maybe in poor taste about
killing an intern.
Secondly, Joe Scarborough and Don Imus were
not the presidents of the United States.
They weren't president of the United States.
Tweeting bogus death accusations, bogus killing
allegations to their 80 million followers,
which is what Donald Trump is doing.
Then she says, well, Joe Scarborough's co-host,
Mika Brzezinski, once said things we believe
to be false about Donald Trump.
Mika Brzezinski is not the president.
Donald Trump is the president.
There is no relevance or comparison.
Now, in terms of hydroxy chloroquine, people
have died from taking it.
But again, that has nothing to do with Trump.
Accusing people of murder on Twitter were
a joke.
Guys, I hate to say it, but we're a joke.
We have a petulant, incompetent child as the
president tweeting conspiratorial murder allegations
against the TV host that he simply doesn't
like.
The president is accusing people of murder
on Twitter.
The press secretary is defending it by saying,
well, other people said things we don't like.
That's the defense.
But we're talking about the president.
She has nothing to say in reality because
there is nothing to say.
She represents nothing.
She is the spokeswoman for a mad man and she
doesn't care.
How does she sleep at night?
She claims to be some kind of supposed Christian.
That's probably a story for another day, but
absolutely unconscionable.
What Trump is doing.
How Kaley Magnani is defending it.
And the complete lack of Donald Trump ever.
I mean, he you know, earlier I jokingly said
Trump apologized for tweeting fake news.
He he just never.
He doesn't take responsibility for anything.
He doesn't take responsibility for the unnecessary
corona virus deaths, which are not the full
100000, of course.
Right.
I mean, but but some fraction certainly would
have been avoided.
Up to 60 percent, according to a recent study,
had Trump acted earlier.
He doesn't take responsibility for lack of
testing.
He doesn't just say, you know what?
It was over the line to go after Joe Scarborough
in this unfounded way.
It did bring unnecessary pain to the family
of the victim, Laurie Kessler.
He will never do it.
And if you're holding your breath, waiting
for him to do it, you will soon die from from
asphyxiation because he's simply not going
to do it